you wear the same outfit for a week many
people across the valley do and it's not
by choice one group of women plans to do
just that to draw attention to and spark
a conversation about poverty in our
community junior league of las vegas
will host the little black dress
initiative this week these ladies will
wear the same little black dress for
five days and raise money to help
families in need the goal is to talk
with friends family and co-workers about
this issue and offer ways to give a hand
here in las vegas and in southern nevada
one in six families is below the poverty
line and one in three children face
hunger and
food insecurity issues
hunger and homelessness do not
discriminate it affects women children
veterans uh senior citizens it impacts
people all over our valley and we the
women of junior
league believe it's our duty to commit
and engage and to help people
this year the league wants to raise
twenty five thousand dollars a five
dollar donation can provide meals to a
child for a week and twenty five dollars
can buy a jacket and a hat for a child
in need this winter this week they will
also pack hygiene kits for the shannon
west homeless youth center to learn more
visit ldbi22.givesmart.com